um do you have a dream about your
characters this is another of our
competition winners this is from Sharon
Curtis in Ontario do you ever dream
about your characters and your world no
not at night I do a lot of writing with
daydreams as we used to call them
sometimes just before I go to sleep when
I'm in you know I'm in bed and I'm
reading something I usually read a
little before I go to sleep and I tried
to light I'm trying to sleep but I don't
go right to sleep and that's when my
mind turns to my characters and and
they're going around in my head also on
on trips I mean back in the 1970s when I
was living and working in Chicago I had
about a half-hour ride on the elevated
train from the part of Chicago we'll
live down to the loop where I worked and
I would sit there and watch the scenery
go by on the L and then Arab Lee I would
start thinking about stories and
characters you know I'm staring out but
I've seen the scenery a million times
before and my mind is just racing ahead
of me and I still do that when when I'm
driving on a long drive or something
like that it's like you're awake and
your mind is working but there's no
immediate stimulus or anything like that
and suddenly the stories start bubbling
up but nothing full sleep know that my
dreams are usually incoherent nonsense
to everyone you know I I mean like most
writers I said at some point in my
career I know a lot of writers had this
experience you know say oh I I have such
great interesting dreams but I always
forget them in the morning so I'll leave
a pad by my bedside so I'll write them
down you know and and you have a dream
and you have some incredible dream and
you you write it down and the next
morning you wake up and you've written
purple sauce
[Laughter]
okay what the hell was I thinking do you
not find that you can solve problems
that way though do you not find that in
that hypnagogic state when you just
before you're fully awake in the morning
that sometimes solutions come to you for
writing problems oh yeah maybe I don't
know where the solutions come from
writing is weird man
it's weird I act I know I don't solve
problems with my rational brain like the
way you people solve problems in life
you know you know should I take this new
job or should I keep my old job let's
make a pro and con list and way well you
know higher salary moving costs you know
etc etc you're doing that it's a very
rational means of solving a problem or
with the movie theater I bought in Santa
Fe when we get a problem there and I
meet with my manager and we discussed
possible solutions we use our rational
brains to solve the problem or to reach
a decision absolutely no good when
writing I don't know where I reset this
is horrible what would I do here I've
written myself into a dead-end and then
I kind of abandoned that character for a
while fortunately I have a lot of
characters so if I totally mess up with
Tyrion I can just switch to Arya for a
while and write about her and then one
day suddenly there's the solution to the
Tyrion problem where the hell did that
come from it wasn't there yesterday and
now I just thought of it and they why do
I see that all along yes that's exactly
what it's got to be I should have seen
that since the beginning so it's unless
you go with the ancient Greeks and
believe in muses whispering in your ear
it's coming from inside me but I don't
know what part of me is coming from it's
not coming from the rational brain
there's a back room in the back of your
head and everybody works on it and at
the right time the messenger runs to the
front says okay here's what you do but
they get lost out of the way
I've never dreamed about my own
characters but I have incorporated dream
territory into books yes
the the treasure Beach and the other
Island was was from a dream I had that
was very peculiar and disturbing and
made its way into the book but sometimes
when I am stuck and I will sit there
I've become irresistible sleepy just
really really tired and you try to fight
it off because you know you've got to
get something done but if I give in and
I go just Sam I'm just gonna lay down on
the couch for 20 minutes and and and
rest sometimes in that preview you sink
right down because you're so sleepy and
you're gonna fall asleep but instead you
get in that place where you're you're
skipping along the surface and you're
not awaking you're not asleep and
suddenly oh now I know what I need to do
in that scene so it's not dreaming
really it's like disengaging and and
waiting for that messenger to make its
way forward disengaging was good
actually I think yes that's what it is
it's getting everything else peels away
doesn't it suddenly some clarity comes
through from somewhere goodness knows
where the news is is as good an
explanation as any my hearing hearing
voices while you're in the skillet
there's also the Raymond Chandler
solution that if you get stuck if
someone comes through the door with a
gun it would be really nice startling if
someone came through a door with a gun
and in a game of game problems someone
had a question on Twitter's a day with
which you ever sort of go far future
into Westeros and actually have
technology that would be hilarious